now russian president vladimir putin
announced wednesday that future payments
for his country's gas exports must be
made in rubles many see an effort to
undermine western sanctions and prop up
russia's struggling currency
as explained by putin the new rule would
apply to countries sanctioning russia
but still receiving its gas exports a
list that includes the eu and japan
a number of western countries have taken
illegitimate decisions on the so-called
freezing of russian assets
[Music]
this collective west has actually drawn
a line under the reliability of its
currencies
you've already spoken about this
it crossed out the trust in these
currencies
but existing contracts are in dollars
and euros making the move dubious at
best
the announcement to pay in rubles is
first and foremost a breach of contracts
and we will now talk with our european
partners about how we respond to this
it's also unclear how payments would
even take place
western banks don't trade heavily in
rubles russian banks could exchange the
currencies
but that would undermine sanctions
giving russia much needed foreign
currency
and in turn strengthening the weakened
ruble
i don't think it is practicable and we
already hear that not only germany but
italy and austria have already declared
that they will continue to uh deal uh
with gas prom according to the existing
contracts which means that the
payment will be made in euro or dollar
which also means that putin's demand
further complicates the eu's long and
painful divorce from russian fossil
fuels
earlier i spoke to yen sudukum a
professor for international economics at
the dusseldorf institute for competition
economics i asked him what russia is
hoping to achieve with its ruble payment
demand
i think he's testing the west
so yesterday uh morning the chancellor
olaf schultz he spoke in parliament
essentially saying that we are not
aiming for a gas embargo essentially
because we still need the gas we cannot
just turn it off
and now putin is playing games and
testing how far we're going to go
because he knows says well you can have
the gas but only if you pay rubles
will eu countries do it will they pay in
rubles
i think the likely scenario is
that they will not do that i mean we're
talking about long-term contracts and uh
they are in euro or dollar so putin
cannot just come along and change the
rules uh i mean if we would do that
that would be a very weak signal
actually on the other hand i mean we
still rely especially germany a few
other eastern european countries um
we still rely heavily on gas so the
other option
would be that we kind of downplay what
has happened and say well it doesn't
really make a difference whether we pay
gas prom in in euro and then gazprom
transfers the money to the central bank
of russia and there is the exchange to
rubles um in the new scenario we would
essentially just exchange at a different
russian bank
euros for rubles and then pay gas form
and rubles it's not a
big difference factually speaking it's
just that just puting comes along and
changes the rules this is basically the
the difficult point
some have said that this is a way to
sort of undercut eu sanctions and
western sanctions uh on moscow do you
think that's that's true
yeah that's right i mean
at the moment basically we pay gas from
in euro or dollar then that ends up at
the central bank of russia which is
sanctioned and so basically they have to
find workarounds and loopholes how they
can make use of that hard currency to
essentially um
affect the exchange rates on
international markets now ways their
workarounds they can operate via china
and so on and so forth but it's
difficult so under the new set of rules
basically we can make life easier for
the central bank of russia because we
would essentially allow the commercial
banks of russia
to uh stabilize the exchange rates
because they would basically um change
make this transaction of um dollar euro
versus ruble for the central bank
so essentially factually basically
it would undercut the century that we
have imposed because we wanted to affect
the central bank we didn't want the
central bank to operate international
financial markets
if we follow putin we will effectually
allow um commercial banks to do the job
of the central bank
so what kind of impact will this have on
on eu gas supply which as we know is
already quite stretched
yeah well that depends on what
governments will decide whether they
play according to uh putin's book and
downplay the impact i mean then
factually speaking i mean basically
things could business code go on as
usual and we just pay rubles as i said i
mean it's a technical detail we could do
it but i think the more likely scenario
is that we see an escalation of the
conflict so basically european countries
say no uh we stick to the contracts
they're specified in dollar euro that's
what we're going to do
and then well we'll see how putin will
react um
in the extreme scenario you can say
yeah well i mean uh in the extreme
scenario um putin will just close the
drain for gas
shares in russian equities including
glasprom and burbank can be traded from
thursday but the end of the longest
closure of the country stock market in
its history comes with some limits
there's still a ban on short selling and
foreigners are not allowed to exit local
equities but that may not be enough to
stop a sell-off
european stocks with major exposure to
russia lost more than 100 billion
dollars in market value within days of
russia's invasion of ukraine according
to an estimate by bloomberg news early
this month
meanwhile the ruble has also plunged on
february 24th the day russia invaded
ukraine one dollar was worth 84 rubles
on march 23rd one dollar was worth
around 97 rubles
today russian businesses are isolated
due to western sanctions most banks are
blocked from swift the international
payment system
and russia's central bank cannot access
around half of its foreign reserves
several multinationals have also decided
to quit the market
as part of a boycott making it even less
attractive to do business in russia
now let's bring in timothy ash he's a
senior sovereign strategist for emerging
markets at blue bay asset management tim
thanks so much for joining us so we did
see russian
the russian benchmark index rise today
what do you make of that
well it's pretty artificial uh firstly
short selling of stock is not allowed
that's a very limited
section of stocks
for uh for sale or you can trade
foreigners allowed to trade them and the
russian sovereign wealth fund has uh has
basically put it's put aside 10 billion
dollars to buy stocks and this has
really been artificially maintained
because russia wants to portray an image
that there's stability and it's it's uh
it's regained
what regains stability on its financial
markets
yeah i guess you mentioned 10 billion
dollars that the russian sovereign
wealth fund has used to help prop up the
market russia is obviously pretty cash
strapped right now what is what is the
purpose of of using that precious
foreign exchange that precious cash to
prop up stocks
well they they want to send a general
message to the population of of
stability and confidence remember uh the
the the the invasion the sanctions came
as a massive shock to russia's
population they believed the lies of the
kremlin that they weren't going to
invade so the biggest holders of russian
financial assets are russians themselves
foreign has sold out so russians were
under massive amount of pain because of
because of sanctions in the collapse of
russian financial markets and there was
concern about a run on banks and a
broader collapse of macro financial
stability so so it's all about sending a
message that things are okay everyone
needs to calm down the russian
authorities have got everything in
control but it's as i said it's
artificial it's artificially maintained
the longer term story is dreadful
sanctions gonna remain in place for a
very long time the outlook for the
russian economy is terrible there's no
real reason to invest in russian assets
at this point in time
there also um
is continuing discussions here in the eu
really around the world
about what further sanctions should be
put into place what do you see coming
next in terms of sanctions
well i think energy should be sanctioned
and germany's central there because for
years it's been appeasing putin and it's
depend it's over dependency on any on
russian energy is its own fault right
sure
sanctioning russian energy would have a
big hit to the german economy growth
would slow but germany has the strongest
fiscal in the eu it can offset the the
recessionary impacts of of banning
russian energy by pump priming growth
with fiscal channel you know i think
this is time for germany to stand up
actually it's uh you know energy
sanctions are the one one that's the key
angle that the west can hurt putin and
maybe stop in with this invasion on the
of ukraine
there has obviously been a lot of
resistance to that here in germany which
is one of the biggest eu importers of
natural gas
do you get a sense that that that
resistance is shifting at this point
well if you think about sanctions there
was a lot of resistance to swift
sanctions from germany amongst other
countries
uh resistance to cbr sanctions uh
remember a lot of these companies i mean
self-sanctioning has been the new thing
that companies have been embarrassed uh
by the fact that they're still doing
business with russia and and you know
putin the war criminal and the stuff
that he's been doing in ukraine um i
think the embarrassment is a massive
factor of
working towards momentum in terms of
sanctions and i think in in the end the
german government itself could be
embarrassed into actually rolling over
in terms of the energy sanctions option
one thing that's been talked about is an
iraq-style food for oil program that
that might be interesting and might be a
a middle ground i guess between a full
ban on uh imports from from from russia
that could probably help some kind of
transition
exactly would that look like an oil uh
an oil for food program
yeah so sure so so any exports of oil or
energy by russia
would be paid for and the monies would
go in an offshore scroll account that
would be managed by the international
community and when russia needed to use
them it could only use them for few food
or humanitarian
reasons it was imposed on saddam hussein
if you remember
after the the first gulf war uh and was
pretty damaging in terms of uh the the
the iraqi economy at that point in time
timothy ash from blue bay asset
management thank you so much for joining
us
my pleasure